i had this idea for a show
different women
different points of view
maybe a little too different
[Music]
we call it the view
[Applause]
how you know people i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report it is july 27th
2022 we're live streaming on rumble
youtube and blaze tv subscribe if you
haven't and today
it brings me no great pleasure but i'm
going to have to demolish
the women of the view you know we often
play clips of the ladies of the view on
this program i often mock them your
honor navarros
your
sunny hostins your joy behar's your
whoopi goldbergs etc i often mock them i
make fun of them we show their clips
sometimes we just show their clips i
don't say much because they're mocking
themselves
but actually and somewhat joking aside
not fully joking aside whoopi
did something so horrible yesterday
and it was so retracted slightly in real
time
that i'm going to have to destroy
those women today and that show it
actually is an embarrassment and it is
on right now as some of you know on abc
right now if you still have
television i don't have a television
anymore but if you still have a
television uh you could be side by side
watching me right now and whoopi
goldberg's giant head on that uh
television screen right at this very
moment but the reason that i talk about
the view often is because whether we
like it or not whether they have all
become hysterical harpies or not whether
the show is completely counter to what
we just showed you there in the cold
open or not which it is right barbara
walters talked about having a show about
these diverse women different walks of
life all of this stuff and sometimes it
would get a little spicy and it's
devolved into just leftist lunacy and
propaganda and lies and everything else
but whether we like it or not it
is still culturally relevant there is a
set particularly of women of a certain
age
say say
25 to probably late 60s if not more of
mostly females who pay an awful lot of
attention to that show
and whoopi did something yesterday that
was such a direct lie about a turning
point event that i did this past weekend
where she said that nazis showed up and
that turning point welcomed then it
welcomed them in that i now have to
destroy whoopi goldberg and i i liked uh
you know
what was she in she was in sister act i
liked sister act too
i liked ghost
you know i like some i like soap dish
very underrated uh but whoopi you've
just become a horrible person i have to
destroy you and i then i think also will
have to continue i'll have to go a
little bit further and destroy their
whole ridiculous
faux racist agenda and contrast that
with a pro-america agenda contrast that
with a pro-individual rights agenda
contrast that with a pro-freedom america
that is trying to grow right now but
it's constantly
having you know poison put on it by
these people and uh so it brings me no
great pleasure a little bit of pleasure
but that's it i have to destroy you
people today that's the plan that's what
i'm doing so sit back get your coffee
and uh here we go real quick before we
do it let me talk to you guys about
bullying max you know as inflation
surpasses high it's not seen in 40 years
the value of the dollar is decreasing
with every passing day you're paying
more at the pump the grocery store for
cars and housing face it your paper
money is worth less friends the timing
couldn't be any better for my new
sponsor bullion max bullion max is a
direct to consumer precious metals
retailer who can help you diversify into
gold and silver it's a hedge against
inflation it's also security to your
family in times of crisis and here's why
i love bullying max they're owned by
veterans in the precious metal space and
offers some of the lowest prices on the
internet and they make it so easy to buy
directly from their website i want to
help you get started so i worked out a
special offer just for you go to bullion
or you can get bullion max's silver
starter kit at employee pricing just go
to bullionmax.com dave this kit includes
five of the most desirable silver
products to invest in including a silver
american eagle and a silver australian
kangaroo this offer is limited to just
one per household so get yours now go to
bullionmax.com
dave and now back to me okay so
yesterday on the view
out of nowhere they decided to basically
just make a statement like announce that
they had to say something about the
turning point student action summit that
was this past weekend that was an event
that i was at if you watch yesterday's
show we showed you a little clip of my
speech there we're working on getting
the full speech so we'll post that on
the channel in the coming days but just
it had no context on the show they
suddenly just had to say
that
these nazis were at turning point it was
it was completely out of left field and
bizarre so all right take a look
oh okay so you have to read this thing
oh i've got a legal note uh the
conservative sonny normally
the conservative group turning point usa
has condemned the group of neo-nazis and
said they have nothing to do with the
organization yeah but where was this
fantastic
but you left them in front of them you
let them in and you knew what they were
right so you are complicit we'll be
right back
okay
these crazy [ __ ] have no idea what
they're talking about no idea what
they're talking about now first off
these neo-nazis now we're going to show
you some video of the five or six
neo-nazis who showed up they were not
allowed inside they were pushed back by
security and some of the attendees who
were actual turning point students and
staff got into arguments about them
because or got into arguments with them
because the turning point people don't
like nazis uh they like freedom they
like america they don't like
collectivism and racialism and all of
those things and also it was very clear
that these were actors these were staged
people not real nazis their flags were
brand new their faces completely covered
like it was just so obvious that these
were actors most likely lefties who were
trying to pit it as if there were nazis
that were supporting turning point which
is and then you get these morons on the
media to pretend that's actually true so
joy behar
who who is basically brain dead joy
behar she said where was desantis where
was desantis well
it's funny because desantis spoke at the
turning point thing on friday night i
was actually with him on the other side
of the state the next day at the
sunshine summit the day that the nazis
these very real nazis showed up so where
was desantis so why does she say that
just it seemingly is off the cuff just
as they're cutting to commercial because
what she wants to do is connect they
want to connect turning point to nazis
and they want to connect ron desantis
and obviously donald trump to nazis so
whoopi so joy where where's ronda santos
what do you mean where is ron desantis
he's not just hanging out with the nazis
outside you ridiculous clowns you
ridiculous ridiculous clowns so whoopi
basically says there she has no idea
what the event is about and having been
at the event where desantis spoke and
trump spoke and greg gutfeld spoke and
obviously charlie kirk spoke uh and
kaylee mcinerney spoke and a whole bunch
of conservative thought leaders you may
not like all the people
they may not agree with all the people
but i was there there was not a word of
bigotry said they talked about freedom
and individual rights and limited
government
they actually talked about how there is
now this wide tent and i talked about it
myself this wide tent movement on on the
right now that is welcoming of all of
these minorities not because they're pet
minorities the way the democrats want
them but because we treat people equally
and all of those things which actually
is the greatest kryptonite to these
collectivist buffoons so whoopi just
says oh they welcomed them in they just
welcomed them in the nazis were there
and they welcomed in the implication
being hey now oh my god we got a couple
nazis guys open up the doors bring in
the nazis and let's you know get them to
the buffet
complete nonsense they were arguing with
them and not letting them in and then
every now and again on network
television they have to correct
themselves because they are complete
abject morons whoopi
i made a quick clarification about the
neo-nazis at the turning point event
they were outside protesters my point
was more metaphorical that you you
embraced them at your thing i felt so i
just they were not in the building
no but you know okay you know what if
this so-called antifa who are
anti-fascists that's what antifa stands
for would go there and protest then
antifa would get a bad reputation that's
why when i hear that antifa is that
right but that's not but let me just
make sure that everybody because you
know misunderstanding what people say is
very big yeah i know yeah so we want to
make sure you i know they were not in
the building but they were
in the mix of people
at the thing
no they weren't you stupid [ __ ] they
were not sorry guys sorry they weren't
there's nothing else i can say to these
people they were not welcomed in in any
way they were pushed back completely and
you know what happened there first off
what the hell is joy saying about antifa
these people their minds have actually
melted their joy the the restylane and
the botox they i know they were trying
to just keep the face going but i think
it went directly in the brain okay so
put that aside right uh whoopi clearly
what happened there is they went to
commercial break and the lawyers freaked
out because she knows that they
because the lawyers know that they
absolutely lied these people had nothing
to do with turning point they were not
welcomed i oh yes they were welcomed in
metaphorically no
literally nor metaphorically were they
welcomed in literally would be hey guys
come on in and uh let's hang out and uh
you know let's want to get up on stage
and share that nazi message
metaphorically would sort of be like oh
you guys are kind of cool we dig you uh
can't fully bring in but let's hang out
it was completely
the reverse of that so whoopi then
suddenly was freaking out because the
lawyers and try to imagine how many
lawyers how many
empty soulless suit people watch and
pay attention to every word that these
harpies say because they don't know what
they're talking about and they knew they
were about to get sued into oblivion so
whoopi's apology actually in my
estimation i'm not a lawyer um we'll
have to find a find an actual lawyer on
this but whoopi's
actual apology was worse because she
said it okay they didn't literally come
in but it was metaphorically lit but no
they did not
all right uh here's a quote from turning
point usa on what actually went down
turning point usa 100 condemns those
ideologies in the strongest of terms
since these individuals were located on
public property our security attempted
to but was not permitted to remove them
we have no idea who they are or why they
were at the convention center they have
nothing to do with turning point usa our
event or our students our students after
initially confronting them ultimately
took the mature route and vacated the
space once that happened these
individuals left that's from andrew
culvert turning point usa spokesman i
saw andrew actually backstage right
before i gave my talk and he was if he
was upset it was only that the media he
knew what was going to happen
he knew that these people had nothing to
do with turning point he knew he knew
and knows it's completely counter nazism
collectivism is completely 100
180 degree difference opposite than the
message that turning point is trying to
push okay and he knew that the media was
going to do exactly what whoopee and joy
these brainless buffoons what they were
going to do and how they were gonna
frame it so here's here's some video of
the the nazis these are very serious
nazis these obviously are not larping
characters or potential plants or
leftists these are serious nazis here
they are just getting into it with some
turning point security in students
[Music]
all right so yes there were a couple
people with flags that looked brand new
like right out i don't know where you
get a nazi flag but they look like they
were pretty much brand new they were you
know they had someone said they had
creases on the flags like these are not
like old school nazis with their old
school flags it was it was either some
false flag thing or some plan thing and
if they were legit if these four
or six legit nazis showed up they were
in no way welcomed in metaphorically nor
literally uh and this is what they do
and so there's a reason this one struck
me as we have to talk about it because
not only was i there did i actually see
it
but this is exactly what the media does
with every look there's me i was there
see we proved it look at that logo look
at me that's saying something very
important obviously i mean there i am
doing my thing on stage um
that this is what they do with
everything if you are on the right or if
you just not if you're just not a brain
dead woke leftist they will find someone
who is crazy or they will fake someone
who is crazy and they will try to
condemn you for it and they will say the
most insane
dishonest things and they will always
get away with it or in this case they
will get as close as they can to get
away with it until the lawyers freak out
i wish i wish there was somebody in the
audience one of these seals that sit in
the audience with the mask on who had
the video of some network suit running
out there to whoopi to explain to her
that she is about to get sued into
oblivion and they're going to destroy
the show
and then she gives that absolutely
ridiculous apology abs you know it's the
same equivalent of me just saying you
know i'm sure that there are some nazis
that are at the the view there's got to
be right they're doing this show every
day you'd imagine some nazis are showing
up and sitting in the view audience and
that means if there's one nazi there you
know how nazis operate if you get one
nazi it's like gremlins in a pool they
start spreading then all of the uh all
of the audience is nazis and then at
that point we're talking about you know
the audio guy the the cameraman uh the
ladies of the view i'm talking serious
nazi stuff okay but whoopi is an idiot
whoopi is an idiot and again this i take
no pleasure this i used to love whoopi
goldberg i really did she was a
wonderful wonderful actress
a ghost and ghost you know molly you in
danger girl like she was great she was
great i remember watching the the oscars
when she got the speech when she won for
i think it was best supporting actress
for ghosts like
you used to love her she was great when
she used to do the stuff with uh with
billy crystal and robin williams uh all
the the comedy hbo comedy specials but
now she is in over her head she says
endlessly stupid things but when you're
on the left you can say at least these
stupid things and you get you get
usually you get promoted for it on the
right you get punished and cancelled and
all that stuff so we i said i said
phoenix can we find some stupid stuff
that uh whoopi said and phoenix said i
have a limited amount of time during the
day there's a lot of it how where are we
where are we going to start here uh
here's whoopi just a few months ago on
the holocaust
well also if you're going to do this
then let's be truthful about it because
the holocaust isn't about race
no no
it's not about race
a different race but it's it's not about
race
it's not about race is it about because
you it's about man's inhumanity to man
that's what it's about but it's about
white supremacy
but it's not it's not about ideas
but these are two white groups of people
well how do we have to blame
him as white
the point the people you turn it into
race it goes down this alley let's talk
about it for what it is it's how people
treat each other
oh whoopi oh so you may remember when
that happened whoopi ended up getting
suspended with pay for two weeks so she
got a two-week paid vacation uh for
saying that the holocaust had nothing to
do with race uh i'm not a historian or a
biologist uh but i do remember something
about that hitler guy
i'm not talking about orange hitler i'm
talking about hitler hitler mustache
hitler uh he said something about the
master race wasn't it something about
and he really liked those people and
didn't like didn't right he didn't oh
and then he would put numbers on other
people's arms the people that were not
in the master race and send them into
gas chambers and all that stuff so
whoopi is a complete idiot
complete [ __ ] there's i don't know what
else to say about her right like
maybe that's not the most astute
political analysis but like what else
can you say about this woman anyway so
then yesterday we're going to flash back
to what happened yesterday so she says
this lie
then they come back from this complete
abject lie and whoopi's you know enjoys
it on it where's the scientist
can you imagine just her like coffee
breath i feel like joy has horrible
coffee breath it's like a combo of
coffee and pinot grigio so so you got um
you got whoopi lying then they freak out
they come back from commercial she digs
even deeper and then later in the show
now
they realize like they've just like
completely lost control of this thing so
here's whoopi saying possibly the most
ironic thing in the history of
television this might be it irony you
are truly dead
look i realize people just want to be
[ __ ] about stuff
they just want to be [ __ ] and i have
to stop asking these dumb questions
about why
stupidity rises to the top
and all the mediocracy rises to the top
when really smart thinking seems to be
struggling to get up
we could end the stream right now like
what else can i possibly she literally
took a mirror to herself
and she pointed it towards other people
you are that
you crazy lady you are that you are
mediocre you are not a real thought
leader or an interesting person you are
in over their your head you are an
actress
who then suddenly magically became
someone that started talking for a
living and the thing with actors guys
this is an important piece if you don't
know this about actors and i did take
acting class for a couple weeks back in
around 2008 actors read other people's
words they don't really think those
things
tom hanks for example was not stranded
on that island okay
um who's another actor give me an actor
of your of choice name an actor any
actor
ryan gosling uh did not uh what's the
movie ryan gosling was in with with
did not he was in drive that's right
ryan gosling i guess he drove that car
maybe
that wasn't a good one well probably a
stump man drove the car the point is
these people are mostly self-absorbed
morons and somehow
they put them on television to say the
stupidest things ever anyway so let's
link this to sort of more broadly what's
going on politically because i don't
think that's nothing right there like
yes i get it okay so fine it's the view
these women are stupid and they're
ridiculous and they're pandering and
that's why they get on television but
these racial stones that whoopi casts
that her political opponents this is
pervasive in all institutions on the
left it's pretty much all they've got
and as i always talk about here it's not
just oh okay let's throw desantis's name
in with the neo-nazis so he we can
loosely connect him the way they used to
do with trump it's so that they can make
everyone think if you say anything that
is against them you too are a nazi
before i continue on this nazi hunt
we're going nazi hunting today uh let me
talk to you guys about real estate
agents i trust uh you know buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be 10 times worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are the biggest
investment which is of course a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents they make the introduction and
then follow you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records they're the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go to real estate agents itrust.com
today give them some basic info they'll
contact you they'll get you the
preferred agent you move and you live
happily ever after hopefully very far
away from whoopi and the ladies of the
view so okay how do we connect
sort of the insanity of the view and
just accusing people of being nazis and
literally and metaphorically or
literally or metaphorically welcoming
nazis into the fold how do we connect
that to more broadly what's going on in
society could there be a way to do it
well we found this chiron from cnn
yesterday
dem strategists urging party to label
gop as extremists this is new cnn
reporting by a very serious person isaac
dover he's a cnn senior reporter and
he's talking to those very serious
people and they're saying the quiet part
out loud they're not saying these people
really are extremists they're saying we
the pr people who are basically paid
propagandists we have to start labeling
them extremists and we've been doing it
by the way for a long long time and
you're not going to believe this guys
this actually gets people hurt this
actually destroys property this actually
can get people killed this can lead to
all sorts
of violent confrontations and it's not
just some democrat operative on the
propaganda network of cnn that does it
here is
the elderly man
pretending to be president
joe biden uh talking about donald trump
and kyle rittenhouse and this is from
joe
biden's campaign
launch video so this is back in 2015.
no no i'm sorry not 2015. this is from
uh 2020 obviously man i went into a time
warp right there so you see what
happened you talk about by and you start
thinking like but
this is during biden's election summer
of love so this is as everything's
burning down in the country because of
the democrats um
this is his campaign video and listen to
the way he racializes everything and
accuses people probably of things that
are more connected to him
are you willing tonight to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups and to
say that they need to stand down and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha and as we've
seen in portland are you prepared to
specifically do it i don't say i would
say almost everything i see is from the
left wing not from the right what are
you what are you doing what are you
saying i'm willing to do anything i want
to see
sir say it do it say it
you want to call him what do you want to
call him give me your name give me a
white surprise
and write prophecy
stand back and stand by
[Applause]
okay so that is video from joe biden's
campaign launch and later in the video
joe biden says that the reason he got
back in because remember he took four
years off after eight years with barack
obama was because after charlottesville
donald trump refused to condemn
white supremacy and this became the
biggest meme online that donald trump
said there are very fine people on both
sides well there's plenty of video of
donald trump condemning white supremacy
uh here's donald trump right after
charlottesville actually
we must love each other show affection
for each other and unite together in
condemnation of hatred
bigotry and violence
we must rediscover the bonds of love and
loyalty
that bring us together as americans
racism is evil
and those who cause violence in its name
are criminals and thugs
including the kkk
neo-nazis white supremacists
and other hate groups
that are repugnant to everything we hold
dear
okay so there are many videos of this
you also know that right before
the line of very fine people on both
sides he absolutely condemned neo-nazis
and white supremacists when he said very
fine people on both sides he was
referring to very fine people on both
sides of the debate about what you do
with these statues of say confederate
leaders meaning some people don't want
to take them down or some people want to
put an alternative statue or a plaque
that explains or gives a little context
etc and obviously we can have an honest
well we can have an honest debate about
it but in a sane society everyone would
be able to have an honest uh
conversation about that but biden
launched his campaign on a lie accusing
trump of in essence white supremacy
defending white supremacists and racist
and of course this isn't just about
trump and it's not just about desantis
when joy behar tries to connect him to
these people
you may remember
kyle rittenhouse and kyle rittenhouse
during the the kenosha summer of love
riot uh the administration was calling
him a white supremacist with absolutely
no evidence the president of the united
states called kyle rittenhouse a white
supremacist here's peter ducey asking
jen saki we haven't shown jen saki in a
while here's a throwback sake drink if
you got a little something with you why
did president biden suggest
that kyle rittenhouse on trial in
kenosha is a white supremacist
so peter what i i'm not going to speak
to right now is anything about an
ongoing trial nor the president's past
comments uh what i can reiterate for you
is the president's
view uh that we shouldn't have broadly
speaking uh vigilantes patrolling our
communities with assault weapons we
shouldn't have opportunists corrupting
peaceful protests by rioting and burning
down the communities they claim to
represent
so kyle rittenhouse i'm told now has 24
7 uh security with him i've met him once
or twice at different events
seems like a really decent kid not not a
white supremacist as far as i can tell
there was no evidence by the way that he
was a white supremacist now you could
say okay
he didn't do the right thing or he did
do the right thing or whatever shouldn't
be out there blah blah blah that's all
separate the president of the united
states with no evidence called this kid
a white supremacist and saki knew it
right there which is why she's not going
to get into it but this rhetoric
actually does lead to violence and leads
to the destruction of lives you know we
referenced this a couple days ago but
you may remember
about a year ago here's a quote from fox
news this one involves me because i'm
trying to show you guys how they do it
to everybody
liberal new york times editorial board
member mara gay was roasted tuesday for
claiming in an interview that
commentator dave rubin regularly hosts
white supremacists on his show the
reuben report although in fact she
called it the dave rubin show
gay a frequent critic a critic of
conservatives and republicans on msnbc
made the claim during a newspaper's
editorial endorsement interview with
democratic city mayoral candidate andrew
yang in which she also incorrectly
labeled the show at the dave rubin show
okay fine over the years you've built
your brand by frequently doing radio and
other appearances with right wing media
personalities at times you've said the
democratic party should gravitate away
from identity politics you've supported
automated fast food workers at times why
appear on shows like the dave rubin show
who regularly hosts white supremacists
gay ass yang in the interview okay
doesn't matter about me i really mean
that but i'm trying to show you this is
what they do with everyone and that's
the point the point is not about the
specific thing the point is about the
signal right it is the signal that they
try to send to everybody else okay and
and more broadly they never help
minorities they try to make it seem like
there's this whole group of people that
are out there attacking minorities all
the time
because they aren't obsessed with
minorities right they believe in
individual rights okay so because
they're not obsessed obsessively
pandering to these communities that
means you don't care about them instead
the left just puts in policies that
actually harm their lives
but the point is they label all these
people white supremacists now of course
marigay didn't mention any of the white
supremacists that i've had on the show
or anything like that that's exactly
what they do but i'll get i'll get to
more on what their policies actually do
uh to people in just a sec but real
quick guys i got to show you this we
just got these in the mail i'm very
excited about this uh the blazes
patriotic socks are back you may
remember at the end of last year they
released a limited supply of let's go
brandon's socks so you could show your
patriotism wherever you wanted well
they're comfortable stylish stylish and
best of all worth a laugh we got the big
d energy here that's ron desantis riding
a gator own the libs right there we've
got joe biden he's on the way the road
to hell i did that pretty impressive and
here's klaus schwab from the world
economic forum you will eat the bugs
okay you can get many more of these
socks you get these and many more
there's a whole bunch more these were my
three favorite i got about 20 of them
over there
you can go to
blazesocks.com and use promo code
ruben socks if you would like to wear
some funny meme-worthy socks but okay so
let's now connect this again to sort of
the broader culture war in what's going
on here that these people label everyone
else racist they get as far as they can
they threaten people's lives they
in the case of the election last time
they had half the country believing that
the president of the united states at
the time donald trump was racist when he
obviously wasn't and there was actually
no evidence of it um but they also
basically belittle
actual minorities to the point that they
are irrelevant in their eyes in some
ways you may remember this this is
during uh katanji brown jackson's
confirmation hearings this is about two
months ago
and ted cruz was trying to get to the
heart of this obsession with identity
politics and that you can be whatever
you want and that you know your truth is
more important than the truth so he
asked uh katanji brown jackson an
interesting question for example i'm i'm
an hispanic man could could i decide i
was an asian man would i have the
ability to be an asian man
and challenge harvard's discrimination
because i made that decision
senator i'm not able to answer your
question you're asking me about
hypotheticals and um
how you would assess standing if i if i
came in and said i have decided i
identify as an asian man
so it's interesting what he's doing
there because and i know you guys have
probably seen that clip because what
he's saying is hey when you once
identity politics puts people in those
boxes and then orders those boxes you
will automatically start discriminating
against people right so in the case of
harvard if we want more black people so
we have x amount of black people well
now we have to punish other people so on
its face it sounds right okay well we'd
like more black people at harvard we're
good tolerant liberals
we want to help
so okay we're going to help these people
but you don't have an endless amount of
people you can allow in so you have to
start pun if you're going to help
certain people based on race you're
going to have to punish other people
based on race which is why asians have
been punished at harvard so i use that
as an example of okay they come in with
all of this racial stuff this idea of
racial harmony and we're going to help
all these poor people and these
minorities and actually they end up
punishing other minorities i don't think
we should be discriminating against
discriminating against asian people
katanji brown jackson the entire
democrat machine does believe that we
should
but it's not just their racial stuff
that is actually harming minorities and
poor people
it's their economic stuff i mean this
may be the worst of all of it here is
chief biden economist diane swonk
on what these people are doing and why
they're doing it the worst mistake would
be to allow a repeat of the 1960s and
70s where we let inflation erode living
standards and squeeze profit margins
last
compound a vicious cycle that went on
for years that's worse than recession
it's nothing is good this is between a
rock and a hard place and there's no way
to extract ourselves without there being
some pain
ah i see so you buffoons who printed all
the money and caused all the inflation
and then threw all the money to ukraine
and then caused our supply chain to bust
and then locked everybody down so you
created all the unemployment
there's really nobody to blame here and
we got to have some of this pain this
pain was inevitable no it was not
because again when orange man was
president the economy was absolutely
booming but what she's basically saying
there is all of these policies that
we've put in they're gonna hurt poor and
minority communities the most and it's
not just their economic policies that do
that and you guys all know that what
else what else did the left do there was
something else
in that place that we used to live guys
remember that that horrible place that
we all used to live that that devilish
evil horrible place los angeles oh god
puts money in the jar
they were defunding the police in los
angeles as of course they've been doing
in many uh blue cities and in blue
states across the country and uh
cackling kamala harris she was very
excited about the defunding of the
police in los angeles which of course
hurts minorities the most so does that
mean you support proposals like what
we've seen in los angeles mayor eric
garcetti saying take some of the money
from policing about 150 million dollars
invested in health initiatives training
initiatives for youth
i support investing in communities so
that they become more healthy and
therefore more safe
right now what we're seeing in america
is many cities spend over one third of
their entire city budget on policing but
meanwhile we've been defunding public
schools for years in america we've got
to re-examine what we're doing with
american taxpayer dollars and ask the
question are we getting the right return
on our investment are we actually
creating healthy and safe communities
and that's a legitimate conversation and
it requires a
really critical evaluation i applaud
eric garcetti for doing what he's done
all right so there you have it that was
when they were running for president she
was still a senator at the time and what
did she want she was applauding eric
garcetti for defunding the police and
then the police got defunded in los
angeles just like they got defunded in
portland and seattle and san francisco
and all over the place and then crime
went through the roof murder went up
everywhere murder not good
not good there's some commandment
somewhere in some old thing that says
something about not committing murder
murder went crazy crime petty theft all
of the bad stuff went up rape
the whole thing it all went up uh 81 by
the way this is a staggering number that
we found from quinnipiac polls and they
do they do an actual good job of polling
81 percent of black americans do not
want police defunded this was a democrat
policy much like the economic policies
and some of the other stuff that i've
been talking about that has harmed
minority communities but of course it's
not just their economic policies and
it's not just their policing policies
it's also their language policies these
people don't want you to know the
difference between up and down they
don't want you to know the difference
between left and right they don't want
you to know that two plus two is five or
four actually it's four they don't let
you know the two plus two is four and
what they really don't want you to know
is that there are differences between
boys and girls here's kamala harris
yesterday and my god this is insane
good afternoon i want to welcome these
leaders for coming in to have this very
important discussion
about some of the most pressing issues
of our time
um
i am kamala harris my pronouns are she
and her i am a woman sitting at the
table wearing a blue suit
and
well look at that biologist she knows
she's a woman the fact that this
gender nonsense this pronoun nonsense
has leaked up this high
is crazy like it's really really crazy
and just remember
about five years ago when they were like
20 or 30 of us i would include ben
shapiro in that i would include jordan
peterson and that there were just this
small group of people online who are
saying you know this stuff is real and
it's going to get out of colleges and
it's going to do a lot of damage we were
all called neo-nazis and racists and
everything else the new york times
literally put me and ben and jordan
peterson and milton friedman and thomas
soul on the cover and said we're leading
people to the alt-right that literally
happened
and now you have the vice president of
the united states wearing a mask i don't
know why she's wearing a mask she's been
double vaxxed and triple boosted and god
knows what else
and talking about her not only her
gender pronouns but what color
pant suit she's wearing in case
someone's colorblind and you wouldn't
want to offend them in the oppression
olympics pyramid but minorities are
leaving the left in droves because of
the woke because basically where they're
putting us to get this back to the front
of the show is if you disagree with
whoopi goldberg you're a nazi apologist
and what is all of this actually doing
because every action has a reaction well
you know what it's doing it is bringing
back orange man because he's realizing
that holy shmoley these people will not
stop i stopped them once and maybe i'm
going to have to stop them again
so here is a bit of trump's speech this
past weekend about what's going on need
to get
political correctness and left-wing race
and gender theories out of our military
so that america can once again fight and
win wars we have to be thinking about
winning
we have to abolish all covet mandates
and lockdowns and rehire every patriot
who is fired from the military with
an apology to them and give them their
back pay that they've been looking for
yeah
yeah
yeah
now again we can get into the trump or
desantis thing or how they're going to
work it out and all that stuff but what
he just said there was true and people
know it and that's why people are
excited for whatever is going to happen
on the republican side um but this is
more and more proof that what the left
is doing and the woke agenda it just it
doesn't help minorities it doesn't help
anybody but it certainly doesn't help
minorities uh so now you've got uh
there's donald trump well what's going
on uh with joe biden well we've got some
interesting info here from the wall
street journal
joe biden began his presidency with a
promise to advance equity which means
favoring some races and ethnicities over
others to shrink outcome disparities
like many of his fellow liberal
democrats mr biden is tethered to the
belief that black upward mobility won't
happen without coddling and special
treatment from the government donald
trump's record complicates such claims
this is this is just so beautiful here
over the first three years of mr trump's
presidency blacks and hispanics
experienced record low rates of
unemployment and poverty while wages for
workers at the bottom of the income
scale rose faster than they did for
management part of what made the trump
boom unique however is who benefited the
most the economy grew in ways that
mostly benefited low income and middle
class households categories that cover a
disproportionate number of blacks in
2016 the percentage of blacks who hadn't
completed high school was nearly double
that of whites 15 to 8 percent and the
percentage of adults with a bachelor's
degree was 35 percent whites and only 21
for blacks between 2017 and 2019
those are the years that trump was
president
median household incomes grew by 15.4
among blacks and only 11.5
among whites so now what's interesting
about this i hate all this racial stuff
right so when i when i read something
like that it's like i don't i would like
everybody's income to rise regardless of
their
skin color that really is the point of
the article but it's like i don't take
any great pleasure like oh we got 15.
five percent blacks ray's getting more a
little more money than 11 whites it's
like we got to get over all of that
nonsense by the way i think most of us
have but the point is there that these
people who purport to be all about the
minorities they pander to them and la
tinx they think that they're tacos all
of that stuff
and then their policies actually are
worse for them and then the guy that
they called racist you know for five
years basically his stuff kind of worked
uh but
hispanics or le tinx or tacos as uh jill
biden calls them uh breakfast tacos uh
they're not buying it anymore got a
quote here from fox news president
biden's approval rating among hispanic
americans has plummeted to 26
according to a wednesday poll from
quinnipiac university and we should not
be surprised by this we should not they
have pandered beyond a belief
they have allowed illegal immigrants to
be conflated with legal immigrants which
upsets a lot of legal immigrants who are
here who are hispanic and this is what
they do so the racial slandering and the
woke politicking it's just not working
and on cnn
john king started asking people guys do
we have a problem with this joe biden
guy because this doesn't seem to be
working seeing this in your state in
georgia in the sense that you have
senator warnock who's trying to run for
re-election when he came into office and
helped flip the senate to the democrats
he was a big buddy of joe biden now you
go down on the battleground states like
georgia a lot of democrats are backing
off a little bit because they
politically think they need distance
there's quite a bit of distancing from
warnock's campaign from the president
sorry joe i don't know where you are or
what you're doing or probably who you
are at this point but they are done with
you man they are done with you and
whether you make it
to the midterms or not
i don't know whether they're going to
force you to step down or whatever or
they're going to use you as the
scapegoat after the red wave and they
just just get rid of it right we go but
it's obvious they are done with joe
biden he's dead man walking and he
doesn't even know it he does not even
know it but it is just it is just unfair
because he
ushered in knowingly or unknowingly
ushered in all of this nonsense
um
guys
you're getting chipotle today
with guacamole in honor of whoopi
goldberg we're going to get you a trough
you're all going to eat out of a trough
the way they feed whoopi after the show
a couple comments from the
michael doesn't want to eat out of a
trot but these guys know
very germaphobe over there um a couple
comments from the reuben report locals
community and stick around for a cold
close i found it this morning it's just
completely ridiculous and funny uh easy
breezy says can you start a segment or a
series where you talk about books movies
and tv shows i'm gonna i need to do more
of that on locals i think we're that's
really where i spend most of my personal
time so there are things that i like
outside of politics and we'll do more
over there so i know you're part of the
community already but join us at
reubenreportdownlocals.com uh kamarvi
says whoopi is so angry i would be too
if i were as dumb as her look you know
it's funny when i say these people are
dumb or they're harpies or they're
ridiculous or they're idiots or whatever
it's like there's nothing there's just
not much left to say
what can i say about someone like whoopi
when you do that when she knowingly like
think about what the show did you have
to remember when i do this show it's
it's just what's coming out of my brain
and we sit down for a few minutes and we
try to piece it together the best we can
and we live streaming and it is what it
is i don't you know i have something in
my ear right now because i need to be
able to hear the clips when we play them
for you it's just how the the system
works but nobody's talking to me in my
ear telling me what to say i don't have
a lawyer right over here warning me
about all of these things uh but
think about the machinery the machine is
there a lawyer in this room you're all
laughing right now there is a lawyer oh
we're getting a lawyer okay we're
getting a lawyer after today's show i
know the abc's not going to be happy
with us um
but
i don't want a lawyer in this room there
will be no lawyer in this room um but
think about the machinery around a show
called the view right like you're at a
network abc where you have you literally
have dozens of lawyers you have the
people who have to make sure they can't
use certain language you have the people
with their finger
quite literally on the button i had a
friend who used to do this job at a
network where if they say something a
word or a phrase that they're not
allowed to say there's a button that can
be pressed so they will be silenced or
blurred or beeped or whatever it is
there is such control around that thing
so in some ways it was sort of
intentional what they did they read this
statement on the view accusing turning
point of being around a bunch of nazis
whoopi goes all in on it knowing nothing
about it the lawyers freak out they come
back from commercial she dig i mean it's
just
it's it's theater it's bad theater like
if it was good theater that would be
good or if it was thoughtful theater
that would be nice but it's just
terrible
cliff
since you're going off the grid for a
month soon that's right friday's the
last show until september 1st can you
tell us which reintroduction to society
from your past off the grid experiences
has been the most memorable oh that's a
good question you know what on friday
when we do the off the grid show so i'm
going to do about a two hour stream on
friday we'll answer your questions i'll
tell you a little bit more about
what we're going to be doing and the
babies and some personal stuff and all
that i'll i'll talk about some of the
coming back on the grid shows and what
it was like you know glenn beck has
brought me back and ben shapiro has
brought me back and adam knowles
adam carolla and michael knowles have
brought me back and uh and each one's
been sort of interesting and different
you know this year will be very
different the off-the-grid experience
because obviously we're having a baby
we're not traveling we're hunkering at
home we're nesting as they say
and uh you know it's going to be very
different in terms of life
than you know when i've just been able
to escape and do my thing uh if you want
to play along at home guys join us at
reubenreport.locals.com part two of my
interview with ari fleischer is up
across platforms the full things up ad
free over at locals don't forget the big
friday live stream and now
i leave you with donald trump and joe
biden
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign